Oh, how are you? This is Jyn from Next
Level Commander and today our video is
I'm making this for my friend Jonathan
who is a massive Final Fantasy fan and
trying to get into commander through
this set and but instead of buying a
commander deck or four, he wants to open
a collector's booster box. And these are
his words, uh, if I spend $600, $700 on
a product, Wizards has my back, right?
No way I won't be able to play the game
with that much money spent, right? Well,
today we are going to find out so you
don't have to. Today we have a Final
Fantasy collector's booster box. And
this is for you, Jonathan. So, we'll
open it and try to build a commander
deck out of this. So, this is like the
booster box game, but we always lose.
So, we start with the What is this? The
gift or the box topper as Oh, it's
Hero's Horn. So, if we're building if
we're building tribal, then this is
useful. I don't think we're doing that.
This set has a lot of legendary
creatures, a lot of sagas. Aside from
that, I I don't know what to expect.
Also, I don't really know value. Maybe
I'll do a toil in the end, but for now,
our goal is to try to see how close we
can to a commander deck or multiple
commander decks. All right, let's go.
This box we bought for around
700 650ish. Not 100% sure, but yeah,
super super expensive and you can do a
lot of things with that money, but we
decided to do this. So, here you go.
Starting off with a hero token. I'll
move the packs aside. Hero token and uh
the wandering minstrel. Now, this is the
this is like a landfall kind of deck
with towns. I doubt we're going to get
enough towels. So, I'm going to put him
in the in the useless pile for now.
Joda. Okay, we've been getting a lot of
nice commanders. I mean, Joda is a
definitely a great commander because you
can play because again, this deck is
filled with legends and we can play all
legends. So, we definitely have a Joda
pile and in the pile, why not? We'll put
in the wandering minstrel. Now, for
this, we have Vivv ornate. Yeah, this I
mean I know this card is expensive. I
don't know the rest of the pack, but
this is a Spellinger deck. Can this card
go into go into Joda? Absolutely. Just
because just because I mean this ability
is great wherever. Even if it just asks
two or three mana is already a
ridiculous mana dork, right? Maybe
hopefully Vivv can can run their own
deck. But for now, we'll put Vive in
Joda.
Next up, Balthier and Fran. This is a
vehicle deck. Yeah, vehicle commander. I
don't think this will be useful for our
deck building purposes.
So, nope. Protection magic.
This is great. This is good for a
spellinger deck. You know what? I might
make a few separate piles just for now
because Joda again, this anything can go
into Joda, but for now, we'll try to
find cards that are more synergistic.
So, right now, we have Vivv pile and
Joda pile. Protection magic, spell
slinging. Look, what is this? Somebody
sacrificed. Oh, this is the excellent
counter spell. This could work in Vivv.
We'll see. We have the VV pile. Swamp.
Ah, very playable card.
Clash of Icons. Eons. This is a fight
spell that can work with sagas. I don't
think this is good enough even for a
saga deck, but again, if we need cards
to if we're short on cards, h why not?
We can play it.
Renoa. Renoailli.
When enters create a dog token whenever
attacks another creature gets plus one
plus one. So this is a go wide deck.
Okay, we have a creature kind of
aggressive beat down go white deck will
make her a separate pile. So now we have
yeah I mean production magic can go into
different different decks. So we'll see.
So right now we have I guess three
legendaries,
right? Vivv warrior uh Joda and Renoa
capital city town cycling. This is fine
in five color. Reach for the horizon.
Search for two basic lands. Put them
into the on the battlefield tap with
different names. Okay. Excellent. Reb
spell
and cargo ship. Cargo ship. Uh this add
this is a manador which adds uh what's
for artifacts. We don't have an artifact
deck just yet. Monk's fist.
It's an equipment card. This can go into
Is it Is it good enough for an equipment
deck? Honestly, I don't think so because
it's just two mana. You're make a making
a two- one and then plus one making it a
monk, so probably not. Adventures
airship. This is like a larger
smuggler's copter looks like. Yeah, if
we have a vehicle that I mean boltier
and friend could work, but I mean the
first vehicle we got is blue. So So that
was a long was a long way. So right now
we have three piles for now and we'll
adjust the piles as we open more things.
Uh, this is a removal minus two. If it's
kicked, sacrifice an artifact creature
there. I know you there is some kind of
aristocrat build in this set. So, it's
possible. But for now, we let's see how
many piles we're making. We make in
maybe aristocrats pile because I know
that is a deck. And we make a yeah, like
a spell sling pile
and we'll see. And hopefully Vivv
because two color is difficult. We need
maybe three colors. So Vivvi and Renoa
will go into a deck, a threecolor deck
that we will open soon. Open the
commander. So all right,
token
Zenos when it Zenos enters.
Oh, this is someone that kills someone,
right?
Yeah, it just kills an opponent. No.
Where would we play Zenos? I guess any
legend that we don't know where to put,
we'll put it into warrior of the light,
Joda, just because it's a great card. I
mean, this is a good card. It's kind of
difficult to trigger unless you build
around it, but I mean, who knows?
This is Stroke of Midnight, another
premium premium removal spell. So, yeah,
I hope we get a spell swinger commander
in white because we got some spells. Oh,
is this the one? Whenever you cast non
creature spell, you pay X life where X
is that spell's mana cost. Just what we
were asking for. the spell slender
commander. This is like a what's it
called? Shark typhoon kind of card, but
you have to pay the life. So, what we're
thinking here is we need some life gain
and lots of spells. Okay, sweet.
Unfortunately, unfortunately,
Graa, is it Graa? Graatia is not in
Vivv's color. Otherwise, we'd be we'd be
cooking. But for now, I think this deck
is a lot more likely than this deck is a
lot more likely than Vivie. So the graap
pile looks like this. We have four cards
now in two packs. Four cards. That's
pretty good. Now lice hex non creature
spells you cast cost one less. As long
as you cast two more spells, it's got
double strength. Just reducing the cost
I think is decent. And having a body
that is capable of offense and defense.
I take it. Take it. Looking good. Shadow
mysterious assassin. Whenever a shadow
deals combat damage, you may sacrifice
another non-land permanent. and draw two
cards and they lose life. Now, the draw
two cards is a lot more relevant. I
doubt we're going to have big enough
permanence to sack, but this is the
aristocrat deck. This won't be the
Confederate. But we have the Aristocrat
deck. And this could even work in u in
Graa just because let's see main. Yeah,
all of these cards actually can work in
graa. I might just make it one big pile
and go and go grab
open enough cards. We'll see in the end.
But yes, for now we are going to make
one big pile. Even though se shadow is a
creature, it doesn't trigger gra. But I
I hope I hope I'm pronouncing this right
because uh oh boy, Graha Graha. Uh yeah,
Goen is not a not a non creature, but
we're making tokens and sacrificing them
tokens to to draw cards and I think it's
reasonable. So now we've merged some of
our piles. Next up, Gilgamesh. Now this
does not go into any pile. We built this
before and this is yeah an equipments
commander. If we have an aggressive
equipments deck this will be it is
definitely a theme. So we have a new
pile for that planes.
That is well that is sweet art.
Zedane. Zedane. I love Zedane. But we
are not building Zedane in this deck uh
in this video. So Zedane I don't think
he's useful in anything. So, we'll put
put him in uh in Joda
seems good. Crystal fragments equipment
plus one plus one exile. So, the
transform ability is what's relevant
here. Prevent all damage that will be
dealt to creatures you control this
turn. Tap all creatures your opponents
control. I guess we're starting an
equipment deck.
If we open uh what's his name? Cloud or
something. Togal. Whenever a human
uh when you cast a human, that creature
enters with an additional counter for
each dog or wolf you control. Well,
that's like this is made for Renoa. This
has to be related to Renoa, right? I
mean, I guess yeah, we'll make a pile
here. Random encounter. Shuffle your
library. Mill four cards. Foot creature
cards sh this way onto the battlefield.
Put each creature card this way. They
gain haste. At the beginning of the next
end step, return those creatures to
their owner's hand. So, it's like you
steal them for a turn.
Vivie
Zach far protects a creature interest
with a counter. And uh yeah, this is
like equipment synergy. So, this could
go into Renoa or Gilgamesh, but I'm more
confident in Gilgamesh or or the
equipment deck happening. Um, Missian
Elder. When this creature enters, create
a wizard that is like a mini gutter
snipe. It deals damage, one damage to
each opponent for each non-creature
spell you cast. So everything red goes
into Vivv. We'll see if Vivv can be a
thing. I mean, I hope. I mean, if you
open Vivv, yeah, building around Vivv
sounds sweet. Uh, town. Okay. And Higus,
Gigas, Mountain Cycling, Trample Haste.
Yeah, this is a fine card. We no longer
have a beat down deck. I guess we kind
of do with Renoa. Uh oh, we'll make a
pile. We'll make a pile.
Okay, next pack.
Tifa. Holy. This might be expensive. I'm
not sure, but we don't have a deck for
it. So, beat down. Wow. And Siri Conrad.
That's sweet. We don't have a graveyard
themed deck, but whenever another
creature dies or a creature card is put
into graveyard. So, this doesn't uh this
kind of works with our Esper deck here.
Kind of doesn't. So, for now, we'll put
we'll put Sirard into Joda.
Eye of Nithog. Enchant creature.
Creature becomes a 42 dragon with death
touch and is golded. When I is put into
a battle a graveyard, return it to the
owner's hand.
And thankfully, our commander for says
none creature. And this Yeah, it's super
open.
So, and this is a great card that you
can cast repeatedly to gold your
opponent's creatures. So, this goes in
here. Robon pay life equal to Robin's
power. Ward. Whenever Robin attacks,
attach up to one target equipment to
target creature. Target attacking
creature equipment deck.
The wandering rain again. Oo, summon
Leviathan. Return each creature that
isn't a Kraken, Leviathan, Merolk,
octopus, or serpent to their owner's
hand. And next is whenever one of those
attacks, you draw a card. Very tribal.
Uh, does this go into any deck right
now, enchantment creature? Not really,
but it's a really powerful card. So, we
we'll see. We'll see what we can do with
this. A swep.
Nice. Solen uniform. Choose target
creature you control and target
equipment. Gain control of the equipment
until the end of turn and attach the
equipment. This is way too narrow. And
yeah, it's it's not even a permanent.
It's not even a permanent steel effect.
It's sweet art though, but we're not
going to have a use for this. I doubt
we're going to have a use for this.
Titus Bliss Ball Star. Whenever an
artifact you control entrance, put a
plus one counter. When Titus attacks,
tap target creature. We I doubt we're
going to have an artifact deck. So,
nope. Rufus Shinra.
When Rufus attacks, if you don't control
a creature named Dark Star, create a
Dark Star. Create Dark Star a legendary
two white and black doggo.
Uh, I mean, this is not super specific.
Like, it can we have we have the the
human and dog stack here, so that's
cool. But the color is a bit off. We'll
put Rufus in Joda just for now. Travel
the overworld. Affinity for towns. Draw
four cards. Sorcery. Uh, we can play
some towns, but seven mana, draw four.
It's not great. It's not great. If we
can have one or two towns, it's decent.
Uh, but even then, I I guess we'll put
this in uh as per for now. But it's
probably getting cut unless I mean, we
open two or three counts. That's or Vivv
because Vivv reduce cost. Viv doesn't
reduce cost but Viv can make more mana
but we'll see. Vivv right now is not
really coming together. Uh Dark Knight's
great sword
equipment gets plus three plus one and
is a knight pay three life. This is
cool. Uh we'll see what color the
equipment deck is. Grandpaw's death
touch one. Nope. Nope. Town greeter.
When this creature enters no four cards,
you may put a land card from the one
into your hand. You may put a town card
into your if you if you put a town card
into your hand this way. Don't have
enough towels.
A white or a when this enters exile
something is a mana rock.
This might be okay. Uh well, it's
suboptimal but serviceable again in our
noncreature deck. Noncreature deck. It
can also go into other decks but for now
that's what we have. All right, we'll
continue. Next card.
Oh.
Oh, Sepharov emblem. That's nice. Wait.
Yeah, this is the emblem. Oh, that's
cool. Summon GF Gerber.
Double strike when you next surveil one.
Double strike when you next cast an
instant sorcery. Copy it. So, this is a
spell slinging
saga. When you next cast an instant
sorcery, copy it twice. Yeah, this is
the spellinger saga. Unfortunately,
doesn't go into Esper, but another card
for Vivi. This is Ming Wu Mangora the
Diplomat.
Uh, this is a great card actually in
goes into any white deck really. But for
now, we'll put it into our second most
Oh, it's legendary. Never mind. Goes
into Joda. Goes into Joda. Yuna's
decision. Sacrifice a creature. If you
do draw a card, draw a card, then you
put a creature from your hand onto the
battlefield. Now, this is not great.
Find another way to return one or two
target permanent cards. Four mana. This
is not a great card, honestly. I think,
but sure, we have a green deck. It goes
into our green deck. The Falcon airship
restored. This is the graveyard airship,
I believe. Yeah. When you hit when you
hit someone, sacrifice it, and you can
reanimate a creature, and then it can
also rean reanimate itself. We don't
currently have a graveyard deck, so
we'll put it aside. But oh, it's a
legendary artifact. Does Joda trigger
off legend legendary artifacts here? We
are desperate for
We're desperate for Joda. Okay, Joda
triggers off legendary spells. So, this
goes into Joda. We might have two decks.
Robon. Robon. This we already have it.
It's in the equipment deck. Ancient Adam
adamomentoys. Adamtoise.
Wow. This is the meme card. Aside from
the cactus, this is like the other
turtle. The meme card. All damage will
be dealt to you and other permanence you
control is dealt to this creature
instead. When this creature dies, exile
it. Yeah, we have big green.
Big green mountain. Vanil
cheerful.
When vanil enters, mail two cards,
return a permanence from the graveyard
to your hand. Justice alone is decent.
And there's a melt ability, but the
problem with melt is that we're not
going to we don't there's no partner,
right? So, we can't play them as
commander. And at the same time, they
don't search for each other, right? So,
it's difficult to play something like
this. But this is fine. It's a fine
ability even without the melt. So, we
we'll put her in Joda and hopefully get
the other half. We have summon Fenrare.
Fener search library for a basic land.
put it onto the battlefield, tapped,
then shuffle. And then creatures get
bigger and draw a card. Yeah, this is
serviceable in our wolf human and wolf
tribal apparently. And we found a foil
version of our commander.
Well, our our green, white, red beatdown
deck is going strong, it seems like.
Evil reawaken return target creature
card from Battlefield.
It's five mana. It's fine. We don't have
any creatures in our esper deck in our
Graa deck. So, this might not have a
deck right now. If we find a Graveyard
deck later, then it might go in, but for
now, no place for this card. Phoenix
Down, return target creature with mana
value four or less from your graveyard
to the battlefield tapped. This is also
the
kind of the graveyard deck. Can this
work in
our other decks? It's pro. It's not
terrible. We'll set this aside for now.
Let's see if we need a need a card like
this in the future. Pump bliss ball
shot. We will not play pump spells. Uh
this one summon GF if you may discard a
card if you do draw a card and add red.
Three mana 32.
Not awful. Not awful. Uh enchantment
creature. We'll set this aside for now.
Maybe we have room for this. And this is
a planet beast that can repador. Do we
want to play manadors? Maybe. I think
Madors are I mean we want them to have a
little bit more utility like the tool
here.
Um but we will yeah we'll set this
aside. We'll set this aside. We still
have we still got to have standards. We
can't just put in every card. So next up
hero
safer alasi almasi. Whenever a creature
you control attacks it gains alone
against double strike. Whenever a safe
deals come damage, you may cast instant
sorcery with mana value of three or less
from your graveyard.
Does this work in the in the equipment
stack? Maybe he's holding a sword. I was
my hopes were high, but for now I think
he's more a Joda card. Yeah, I guess he
goes into Joda. Three mana though. Not
sure. Luca Stadium. Whenever you deal
damage, you remove point counter. This
is a stricks haven uh stadium. Yeah. And
it's it's a manor rock, but it also wins
games sometimes. Not usually. And this
is not going to win us games in our
decks, the decks we have now, because we
we're not going white. And it adds one
colorless, so it doesn't go into five
color.
Set this aside for now. The Falcon
again. The Falcon. Yeah, we have. Okay.
Joda Cloud's limit break. Destroy target
type creature. destroy any number of
attack creatures with different
controllers and destroy all attack
creatures. It's a decent spell. Not the
best removal. It's not like stroke of
midnight, but
it's fine. It's a spell. Graa kimari
valiant valiant guardian. At the
beginning of combat, put a counter on
Kimari and tap target creature and you
may have Kimari become a copy of that
creature. Again, this is a legendary
good stuff. Doesn't really fit into any
of our archetypes currently. So Joda
goldz crystal collector whenever an
artifact you control enter survey one at
the beginning of end step if you control
four or more art this is the artifact
commander we don't have a deck for that
you need artifact and a graveyard so
it's way too specific so we'll set this
aside island sure
seat of the sanctum is a mana rock no
it's a land
it's a town five mana mil two cards then
you may sacrifice this to return a
permanent it. It's actually not
terrible.
We're not going to play this in Joda
because five color, but maybe in our
beatdown deck. Maybe. Maybe.
We'll set this aside for now, but we'll
find a deck for it later. Judge
Magister. Whenever another creature or
artifact control dice, put a plus one%
counter. It's a kind of a mediocre
Aristocrats payoff.
Joda.
Joda might win, but I'm not sure how
good it's going to be. So, Fang
Fearless. Oh, is this the other side?
Wait, so
let's take a look. So, the two sides are
different treatment. One is full art,
the other one is normal.
But doesn't matter because we could play
we get to play them. But the key here is
both sides have to be decent. Let's see
thing. Whenever one or more cards leave
your graveyard, you draw a card and you
lose one life. This ability triggers
once a turn. How do cards leave your
graveyard? We're not a graveyard deck,
but if the backside is powerful enough,
we might still do it.
This is sweet. Vigilance, menace,
trample, reach haste. Whenever it dies,
destroy target permanent and return a
non-leendary permanent card. Really?
Really?
I mean, I think we still play it just
because the cards are decent, but this
is Wait, does the front sight say
non-leendary?
Thank god it doesn't. Okay, we they go
into Joda Radius return creatures get
plus three plus three. This is like an
overrun. Return up to two target
permanent cards from your graveyard.
Yeah, this is fine in our in our beatd
down deck that we're still not giving up
on. Ultros, the obnoxious octopus
non-creature spell. If it's for if four
mana was spent, tap target creature when
already cast one creature spell. If at
least eight mana was spent to cast, put
eight plus one counters on altros.
I don't think I mean four mana is Yeah,
I don't think we will have enough to
trigger this. Maybe in Vivv just because
VV can play big mana spells.
Maybe maybe VV big mana spell is a
thing. We'll do that. Okay, next up,
town.
Town, Shinra, Reinforcements, Mill
Three, Gain three. This is for the
graveyard deck. We don't have that yet.
Next pack.
Hero. Oh jeez. What is this? Noctis,
Prince of Lucis.
Oh, this is the graveyard. This is not
the This is the artifact deck.
Okay, maybe we'll we'll take a look
later to see if we have enough artifacts
to make this work, but at the moment I
don't think so. At the moment, I think
we're pretty far behind. If we open some
sweet artifacts, we're going to bring
this back in. But for now, Nature's
Charm. Wow. Destroy Nature's Claim.
Sorry. Nature's Claim. Destroy target
artifact or enchantment is controller
gains three life. It's a decent removal
spell
and serviceable. Not great, but we only
have one green deck. So, Nebblehine of
Flame. Choose target creature you
control. It deals damage equals power to
other creature. Yeah, this is this makes
sense in equipment deck, right? It's
like removal and kind of evasion.
Doesn't work in VV because we're not
really pumping VV, are we? Oh, we're
pumping VV a little bit.
H
maybe in VV it makes more sense.
Yeah, Viv is not giving up. Come for
more shuriken. Whenever this creature
attacks, tap target creature it and Oh,
and then you make up for the difference
in power in plus one counters.
This is not bad. This is not bad.
Equipment sin spy punishment. This is
also a viable commander. This is the
graveyard deck commander. Okay, we're
getting the commanders. Yeah, we're
going to make matters for we will have
to see later because we don't want to
make too many piles, but in the end we
will see. Joshua Phoenix dominant.
Um, Boros cares about graveyard. We
don't have a deck for that. Let's see
the backside.
Press into a phoenix. Deals two damage
to each opponent. Has lifelink.
H just because we are a little bit
a little bit desperate for cards. So
Joda I mean it's it's fine serviceable.
Joda swamp summon choco mog other
creatures you control get plus one plus
oh we don't have a deck for this snow
veilers power equal to no nope
vanilla the other vanilla
other other treatment I mean cool clash
of the icons we saw this one Barrett
Wallace when Barrett attacks it deals
damage equals the number of equip
creatures you control okay this is not a
strong card but it's equipment themed so
Sure. Magite attack infantry plus one.
One mana one one plus one. As long as
control another artifact search for
another one of these. If we open 15
more, we have a deck. Adventures in land
town gain life. Resentful revelation.
Look at top three cards. Put one of them
into your hand. The rest into your
graveyard. That's for the graveyard deck
or the spelling deck. Spelling for now.
Next up, collector booster number I
think number number
seven, I believe.
Hero Aith Gang Pearl. Wow, I'm getting
all the ladies in
in search foil. Whenever you gain life,
put a plus one counter on AF. When Aith
dies, put X plus one counters on each
legendary. Joda it is. We got another
Sconor,
Sid. Equipment and vehicle spells cost
one less to cast. Say no more. This is
the equipment card. Return target
equipment or vehicle. Sure. Equipments.
Benon. Once during each of your turns,
you may cast a creature spell from among
your uh cards in your graveyard.
Whenever you attack, you may pay one and
discard a card if you do draw a card.
Oh, sorry. I missed. Has to be put there
from from the battlefield this turn. So,
the one creature that you loot this
turn, you can cast it if it's a
creature. Sure, Joda. The darkness
crystal. Black spells cost one less to
cast. If a non-token creature opponent
controls will die, instead exile it and
you gain two life. Then you can steal a
creature.
Oh, no. It has to be exiled with dark
crystal. But you can steal a creature
exiled with a plus one counter on it.
Oh, it doesn't say sorcery speed. I just
assumed it would say activate at sorcery
speed, but this would make sense in
spells. Would make le more sense in
spells, less sense in Joda. So we have
that Zenos. We already opened it. Island
Summon Fener. We got this. The Emperor
of Palamia goes into Vivi Ultimacia.
This is our graveyard deck. Ian uh Lo
Cole, sorry. Ian Cole lock. This is also
our graveyard deck. Circle of power. You
draw two cards and lose two life. create
a wizard that pings people and wizards
get plus one plus and lifelink is our
commander here for Esper a wizard. It is
a cat wizard, but it already has
lifelink. But this spell is I mean draw
two cards is already good enough. So
yes, sephro intervention destroy
targeted creature. Say no more. Haste
magic pumps a creature. This makes sense
in Vivv and it can't trip. Yeah, because
you're pumping Vivv, right? As long as
you control seven more. Nope.
Next pack
hero again. How many tokens are there in
this set? I feel like not too many.
Squall seed mercenary.
Whenever a creature control attacks
alone, it gains double strike and when
it deals damage to a player, return
target permanent card with mana value
three or less. I feel like this can go
into the equipment deck just because
double strike works well with
equipments. We haven't opened any
equipments yet. I'm not sure he works
well in Jo. Yeah, maybe decent in Joda.
We'll do Joda for now and later we will
again we'll switch if Ooh, Lightning
Bolt doesn't go into any deck but super
sweet to open.
Oh, we just opened a surge foil of our
commander.
Wait, this is not our commander. This is
the commander deck commander. At the
beginning of each end step, if a player
lost four or more life this turn, you
draw a card.
Whenever you cast a non-creature spell
with mana three or greater, Yashota
deals two damage. Oh, so perfect. Yeah,
and honestly, I was hoping it to be
closer, but at this moment, I don't
think it's particularly close. We are
making escort spells in there. And we
are Well, look at the other decks, too,
in the end. But yeah, we have how many
cards here? We have I'm thinking 10 15
cards. Yeah, Seymour Flux. At the
beginning of upkeep, you may pay one
life. If you do, draw a card and put a
counter on Seymour Flux.
It's a solid. No, it's a legendary
creature. So, cool. Summon Exxion. Exile
target creature opponent controls until
this saga leaves the battlefield.
It's a decent card. Put a counter on it
or on up to two creatures and you gain
two life.
Sure.
Is it a wolf? No, it's not. But marine
white from father to son search for a
vehicle reveal put into your hand. If
it's cast from graveyard you get it onto
the battlefield.
Now we don't have vehicles man. Island
summon summon primal Garuda
deals four damage to a tapped creature.
Another creature
gets plus one and flying. Not I don't
think this is strong enough for
anything. Sashiva tap target creature
for a stun counter. Draw a card for each
tap creature opponent's control. Again,
it's not legendary and it doesn't do
enough for our other decks. Ridia,
whenever a landing control enters, you
may discard a card if you do draw a
card. Oh, and X return target saga card
with mana
with mana value X for the turn because
it leaves. No, it doesn't leave. It just
gains haste, right? All right. So, with
a finality counter and against haste and
activate a sorcery. So, if we have a
saga deck right now, I think we have
five or six cards for saga. So, not
quite enough. We are Yeah, I don't think
we're going to get there. Reno and Rude
legendary menace. When it deals combat
damage, exile the top card. You may
sacrifice another creature or artifact.
If you do, you may play the exile card.
That's just way too much. This is a
terrible, terrible Ragavan variation.
Um, does not go into Joda. We're not
going to play this in Esper. So, nope.
Summon Shiva again. Lunatic Pandora
one mana legendary artifact surveill one
and sacrifice it to destroy something.
This is removal. I don't think we're
going to play this as a removal in any
deck other than the artifact deck. Magic
dumper protects a creature. This is
fine. This is fine. It's a protection
spell for our commander. We'll put this
into Esper for now and but is also do
serviceable in VV. You're not alone.
Just a pump spell. Nope. Okay. Flector
Booster number.
We have four left. Hero. The wondering
minstro again in search foil. Wow. Can't
believe it.
The nea capashi.
Yeah, this goes into equipments.
Wrecking ball our equipment deck plus I
guess seven makes all our creatures
equipped creatures 7 seven. So seems
fine. Master Seymour put a counter
beginning of combat put a counter on a
creature equal to master Seymour's power
and has monstrosity. I mean we have a
counter theme a bit of a counter theme
right
with our green white so it's fine. High
dagger at the beginning of combat on
your turn. Target creature gets bigger
until the end of turn where X is the
number of soldiers you control. Don't
think we have soldiers. Oh, you can
create soldiers at the beginning of your
end step. Create a soldier a number of
white soldiers equal to the number of
opponents who control more creatures
than you. I mean, in our white deck, our
opponents are not going to have more
creatures than us probably. Maybe it's
still fine. Oh, actually I like this in
uh in Graa just because we don't play
creatures, right? So this will play
catchup and at the same time you can
pump our commander for lifelink. So I'm
not sure if I'm trying to force Graa
here, but it makes sense, right? Makes
sense. So Graa, let's go.
Our Realm Reborn other permanent we
control have add one mana of any color.
This card is sweet, but I don't think it
works. I guess we play it in Joda just
because mana fixing is important and in
five color I'm not sure how much how
much budget we have to spend on lands.
So Joda is it legendary? It is not
legendary planes. So dang search foil.
Do we open two of these in search foil?
I'm not sure honestly. Search foil I I
think
uh it's a good for Joda. Are we forcing
it? Do we have worse cars in Joda than
this?
For now, I'd say no, just because the
effect is not really impactful enough.
Omega heartless evolution. When Omega
enters, tap up to one target nonline
prominent that opponent controls. Sorry,
for each opponent. Put X stun counters
on each of those prominence and you gain
X life where X is the number of
non-basic lens you control. Uh, it's
fine. In five color, we won't have many
basics. So when this enters, we will
tapping. We'll be tapping four things
with seven stun counters and gaining
seven life. It's fine. It's fine. Joda
self-destruct target creature control
deals X damage to any target and X
damage to itself. Vivv won't die from
this, but I don't think this spell is
impactful enough for Vivv.
Graa. Wait, Tia. Another Graa.
This says, "Reach. Whenever one or more
other creatures or artifacts you control
die, draw a card." Wow.
Wow.
We don't have an aristocrat deck, but
does this make sense in Graa just
because we can attack people and
feel like we might be forcing it a bit.
We'll put her in Joda for now. If we
have an aristocrat deck, we can put her
in or him her her in. Sorry if I mess it
up. Realm sketching. Create a token that
is copy of target artifact creature or
land. Excellent spell. Summon fat
Chocoo. Create a green bird
that has landfall plus one and creatures
you control. Gain trample. Seems good.
Beat down. Dreams of Laguna. Serveville
one. Draw a card. Flashback. Yeah. And
trigger scrawth.
Black magic. Black mage's rod.
This is another Oh, this is a black
spell singing card, right? it. Oh, you
can turn equipped creatures into into
the black mage. That's fine. I think
that's fine. It also creates a hero
token because it's non non creature.
Three more packs left. I mean, Graa is
looking good, but we're still missing
probably 20 cards. So, we'll see.
Ultima.
Perfect.
This is a foil Carrick.
For each block in a cost, you may pay
two life rather than pay that mana.
Whenever you cast a black spell, put a
plus one counter on Carrick on EMTT
Selch. Yeah, it's a super powerful card.
I don't think it goes into any deck. I
don't think Yeah.
Reluctant Guardian
man for three, four mana. Whenever it
deals damage to a player, you may exile
and transform it.
It's transformed. Each opponent discard
a card and draw a card. Each opponent
sacrifices two creatures of their
choice. Doesn't go into any deck. So,
and it's it's a decent card though. So,
it goes into Jonah.
Rejoin the fight. Mill three cards then
starting with the next opponent. In
order, each opponent chooses a creature
in your graveyard that hasn't been
chosen.
Uh again, we don't have enough
creatures, I think, in uh in Graa to
play this. So, once again, our graveyard
deck is looking good. Maybe
Tataru Taru.
Watch this be the only name only name I
don't mess up. Tataru Taru. When Tataroo
Taru enters, you draw a card and target
opponent may draw a card. Whenever
opponent draws a card, if it isn't that
player's turn, create a treasure tapped
once a turn.
It's a fine. Good stuff card. I mean, I
don't mind just having a legend that
enters and draw a card.
can trips and
oh also makes a treasure with her
ability. Yeah, I think Joda Joda eats.
Okay, summon
Brin. I give up. Exile the top part of
your library. During your turn, you may
put a lore counter on the saga. Sorry.
During any turn you put a lure counter
on the saga, you may play it. When you
next cast a creature spell this turn
against haste. It's pretty aggressive.
Pretty aggressive.
We don't have a H. Maybe, maybe this
deck has red. We don't have a commander
yet. Right now, this deck is green
light, the beatdown deck, but hopefully
we open some naya commander. Uh, but for
now, yeah, this is what we have. Planes
summon Ifit. We already looked at this
black walls number three. Why isn't this
in Esper colors? It's black and red.
This is a cool commander, but we don't
have a deck for it. Also, not Joda.
Unexpected request. Steal something,
untap it, and you may attach any
equipment you control to it.
Not impactful enough for commander.
Poison the waters. Creature get minus
one minus one. And thought seeds. Kind
of thought seas for artifacts or
creatures. Nope. Doesn't do enough.
Ashie, princess of Damasca.
Whenever Ashie attacks, look at the top
five cards of your library. You may
reveal an artifact from among them. So,
this is the artifact card. Insomnia.
Another town and blazing bomb.
Noncreature spell. If at least four mana
spent
gets plus one, sacrifice it, deals
damage. No, I don't know. No, doesn't do
enough. Two more packs. Two more packs.
We will sum things up after this, but
I'd be I'd be really impressed if we're
even halfway to a deck. Sorry, this is
hero. Another Tifa. Wow, that's pretty
sweet. Not search foil, but still pretty
sweet. Kua Inala,
this is the wizard tribal commander.
It's tempting, but we're not building
it.
Uh, Titus Ununas Guardian. This is the
plus one counter commander
or any counters. Okay, this works
because we have sagas and we have plus
one counter cards. So maybe hope time.
Hope is the life gain and mill
commander. I is way too specific for us
to build around it. Does this do
anything in Joda? Not really.
Booen Bugenhagen
Weiss Elder is a manador that if you
have a creature with seven power or
greater, it draws a card. This works in
beatd down also in Joda because Joda
pumps our creatures. Add mana of any
color. I think Joda's closer to to
finishing. So, Joda. Oh, this is a sweet
card. Summon Knights of the Round.
This goes into our beatdown deck.
Yeah.
Forest
prompt to our gentum. Whenever you cast
non creature spell, no
gf if side quest raise a choke. Not
doesn't do enough. Ignis sia. This is
fine. You may ramp tops cards. You may
put a land tap interplay plate tapped.
So, this is fine in Joda. Draon's Lance
Eco has get plus one plus O and it's a
knight in addition to his other types
has flying
again the artifact deck is probably not
happening but we try when this dies
create a one-1 colorless sabotener
whenever landing control nope and uh
scorpion sentinel not quite all right
our last pack
oops
Hero the wind crystal spell white spells
cost one less if you would gain life
gain twice that much life creatures you
control gain flying line I think this
might be a finisher in graa
could also it could go into a lot of
decks but but I think it makes sense in
graa
yeah
new found adventure search for oh it's a
farsek
this is fine in
Joda Emtt Selch. This is the graveyard
deck. When it attacks, draw a card,
discard a card, and if you have 14 cards
in your graveyard, you can transform
this, which can it's like uh Yagmas will
forever on your turn. So, yeah, the
graveyard deck trans. We wait, we didn't
see this yet. Draw a card, discard a
card, you lose one life, and you make a
token. Yeah, beautiful. And this
triggers our commander twice, too, with
rebound, doesn't it?
Yeah, this is sweet. If the darkness
crystal we opened, forest Omega, we
opened Gaas Van Bossar.
Each player sacrifices a creature token
of their choice.
Uh, each player sacrifices a
non-creature token. Non-token creature
and enchantment. Yeah, this is a fine
legend. Poo poo UFO.
Nope. Titus. Not really. Albec
salvagers. Whenever a creature, this
creature or another creature or artifact
you control dies, you drain target
opponent. It's like a crappy blood
artist. Instant ramen. Wow, beautiful
card. Does this do anything in in deck
in an artifact deck? Maybe retrieve the
esper. Create a robot and hectice. When
this creature enters each opponent,
discard a card. Okay, this is our our
pack and we'll be right back. We'll save
some of the expense expensive cards and
we'll make some piles and take a look at
how close we are to at least one
commander deck. I'll see you soon. Okay,
so now we have the decks in piles. Let's
first talk about the ones that didn't
work. Vivv did not work because we don't
have enough enough spells. I really
wanted to make Vivv, but yeah, even with
the blue cards from here, we we're not
close. We're at we're at maybe 15 cards.
Next up is equipments. We didn't open a
commander. But even if we get a
commander from the outside, we we didn't
open enough equipments. Yeah. So, it's a
bit awkward.
It's a cool deck, though. I want to make
this maybe someday. And then Joda is
just a mean Joda. It's there's no
synergy, no cohesion. Joda is the one
one synergy piece. I mean, it's probably
pretty strong, but I'd rather play decks
that are more cohesive, more
synergistic. Okay. And speaking of
synergy, graa tia.
Yes. And this is so good just because
it's so open-ended. You can play any
non-creature spell, right? Sure, you got
to pay life. We need to put in some life
game cards, but at the same time, this
this does unlike a lot of other control
decks, this can close out games, right?
You can make large tokens and just smack
people with them. So, it's solid win
condition, too. All right, we have Yesh.
Uh yeah, just excellent synergy with a
with a commander, right? You can beat
people with your tokens and what's it
called? You you can drain your opponents
when you cast your spells are your big
spells. It's beautiful. Also, apparently
pretty expensive. Uh speaking of spells,
yeah, four mana. Perfect for Yashen,
right?
Also, you gain two life. That's good.
And here, now here you lose two life.
But yeah, all these spells are
excellent. Darkness Crystal. Again, I
like it a lot because you can instant
speed activate this, so it fits in a
control deck. And also, the life gain is
do not underestimate the life game. It's
going to add up.
Great removal spell. This draw spell is
kind of iffy. It's seven mana for four
cards, but I mean, we can play some
towns, right? We open some towns, so
maybe six mana, five mana, and you can
create a large token. This won't get
cut, but for now, it's serviceable. Eye
of Nithog. Decent card. Veins Treachery.
Yeah,
Shadow. This card is I mean again it
makes sense with our commander just
because we're sacrificing tokens, but
aside from that, there's not too much
synergy. This might get cut.
Lice hexed. Great card for a spellinger
build. And unfortunately for the
sacrifice, we we can't really sacrifice
our commander, but but it's still a
decent counter spell at three mana.
Yeah,
Stroke of Midnight Premium Removal. Even
if you get even just building EDH stacks
with the complete card pool, I sometimes
play this because it's it's just solid
solid card. Protection magic. Yeah,
defend your creatures.
Transpose
the wind crystal. Got to gain that life.
Ultima board wipe. Not the best board
wipe, but it does stop your opponent's
like dying triggers, which you don't
have a lot of, so it's decent. Black
mage, dreams of lagona, and uh yeah,
copy something. High dugger again in
this deck is to kind of because we don't
have a lot of creatures. We make
creature tokens though. So depending on
how many tokens we end up making cuz we
may be making large tokens, go tall or
go wide. If you go wide, we have to cut
this. But if not, it's a decent way to
again to block to up the the
battlefield, right? Magic temper
protection and resentful revelation.
Yeah, seems fine. And aside from Yeshota
or sorry, from Kongraa, I'll first count
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20 23. We got 23 cards. Yeah.
So, we are we only need 40 more nonlands
and maybe 37 lands and we have a deck.
But I was going to say aside from Graa,
we got some pleasant surprises. We got
this deck here.
Sin Spyro's punishment. Yeah, I was
talking about a graveyard deck and we
found the the endgame, right? With this
entering, we can bring back every
permanent from the graveyard as long as
we don't have lands. And it's nice in
this deck because because we're not
milling kind of blindly. We are
surveilling. We are choosing what goes
in the graveyard. And we have abilities
that can exile from the graveyard. But
we'll take a look. Send Spyus
Punishment, our top end. And we have
Ignis. Ignis is an awful card, but we
found a use here because again, it's
decent ramp and also it can in a pinch
you can exalt lens from our graveyard.
So that Yeah. So that we don't get lens
for sin. And at the same time, Fenware,
it's kind of strange in this deck, but
if you think about it like a Sakur Trap
Elder, I think it makes sense, right? It
ramps you because Archander is expensive
and at the same time it will die, right?
It will die naturally, which fills our
graveyard and it's just a solid card,
solid value. Lunatic, Pandora, I use it
for the survey ability, but the destroy
can also come come in handy. Newfound
adventure, we just need ramp. also ramp
and we got these two. Yeah, they can
both do work in our mail deck, in our
graveyard deck, I mean. So cool.
Ultimacia with the time travel ability,
the time walk ability can come in handy
because again we have we will have
enough cards in our graveyard. But uh
for the most part just entering and
attacking Serville 2 is not terrible.
It's serviceable, right? And sometimes
you can you can get a pleasant surprise.
EMTT Selch, great card, great enabler
for the graveyard strategy. Selective
discard
the Falcon. Reanimating things from our
graveyard. Rejoin the fight.
Block coal. Not a great card, but still
decent engine if you get it early. Evil
re uh reawakened returns things. And
town greeter. I misread when I open the
pack, but this can get any land. And in
that case, it's decent just because
again, we don't want lands in our
graveyard. So this can mill while saving
the land into our hand. And yeah, we
found a place for Sir Conrad. And this
deck is actually pretty good, pretty
great. And uh Yuna's decision, we put
this in here just because it's recursion
and also you can sacrifice a smaller
creature. And we even put this land in
just because it can return its recursion
and also it can go too. Although putting
this land in the graveyard is not the
best. So let's see how many cards are in
this deck. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 cards. And also there's a
card from here that we can use.
Uh yeah, resentful revelation. There you
go. Fills our graveyard and also has
flashback. What's not to love?
So yeah, we have two skeletons here. And
both seem pretty fun. And there's just
one more that I thought was kind of
cool.
We opened a Titus is one of the
commander decks uh commander deck
commanders and it allows us to move
counters note any counter from creature
to creature. Now it's kind of cool with
post plus one counters but what's
amazing is when you do it with sagas,
right? If you can remove saga counters
onto another saga or onto a creature
even, you can keep reusing the same saga
ability over and over. So uh let's look
at the second ability. Whenever one want
or workers you control with counters
deal damage to a player, you may draw a
card and proliferate. Yeah, this is just
perfect for a counter commander. And
this allows us to use some of the cool
sagas that we opened. We don't know
where else to put it. Summon Leviathan.
Yeah, if you play this uh you can keep
bouncing things if you need to. In a
pinch, you can keep using Titus to
remove a counter and every turn it will
bounce something. It will keep the board
locked down. It will bounce Titus too,
but you can cast Titus on the first main
combat for just three mana. Sorry, first
main face and then you can yeah, you can
get the chain going.
Kimakuri Kimaki is it works with
counters. It doesn't have too much
synergy with close counters, but you can
copy a saga perhaps or you can Yeah, it
has counters to you can move with Kimari
with Titus, I mean to
to
pump something else. Just a solid solid
good stuff. Ath gains borrow. This goes
in here because she can gain life and uh
when she dies you get counters. Also she
has she has counters this synergy all
around. Now Bugenhagen isn't there isn't
too much synergy but it's a decent ramp
card. And also your creatures are
probably going to be bigger than most
creatures. His seven power seems
reasonable. So we have this in here. Why
are your creatures bigger? Because of
our wolf guy tool. our wolf who is a
friend to humans which we have a few of.
Yes, we have some humans and also a
decent manador.
But why we really have uh counters we
have what's it called? Why we are
expecting large creatures is because
master Seymour Master Seymour this this
card will pump your word. This is like
your win condition. You will be pumping
a lot of power onto your creatures and
also monstrosity. you can make himself
huge. Doesn't have to rely on your
commander doing the moving, doing the
pumping. Yeah, tool and also Fenrer
because again with your commander, you
can just keep putting lands onto the
field.
Uh
you can this one you can keep removing
creatures. You will never they will
never come back unless they blow up
Exion.
And this is sweet. Like this is one of
the payoff cards. You just keep making
tokens, right? You move on to I mean it
will take a while but you will get to
what's it called? Chapter four and you
can just keep saving it until you want
to override until you want to do the
plus two plus two. So that's sweet
summon primal Garuda. Another decent
effect. Not amazing but
kill something. And Shiva why not?
and also Ming Wu uh Mangara just because
it's a it's got lifelink right so it can
if you pump Mingvu you can get some
value and also it's just a really good
card in commander and also we have a
card from Graa to go in here
it's the protection spell I mean the
boardw can definitely go in right the
boardw can go in
and uh protection magic specifically
also the removal why not so what do what
do we have we off.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
16 cards. A bit low. We just need
another 37 hands. But again, I'm
pleasantly surprised by the amount of
synergy and cohesion we have in these in
these boxes, even though we just opened
a few packs. So again, I wouldn't open a
box with a goal of building a commander
deck in mind because then you will have
to sell the expensive cards you opened
and uh try to trade them for other
cards. It's a lot of work. Just buy the
precons. But I'm not going to lie, it's
also kind of fun to do. I might do one
another one myself secretly. I won't
tell Jonathan. But yeah, that's all for
the video. Thank you for watching.